cazzo mangione e dentro il gabinetto no
non mi dire che scivola dentro il
gabinetto benvenuti solida stories oggi
nuovissime team rummo dovremmo scappare
dal ragazzo mangione bellissima però è
una delle più votati in atto un robot
dicono che è una delle più belle
quindi per l'occasione io ho messo la
maglietta con le banane e ai fabio
orecchini o dei piattini con i banchi
giorni è coesa ha improvvisato un bel mi
piace per vedere che i forum
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
vi piace binomio eccoci qua stiamo nella
camera del ragazzo mangione che penso
che sia questo sta mangiando fuori come
insieme effettivamente c'è la classifica
dei vincitori
ce la faremo anche noi iniziamo vediamo
un po
e su questo siamo caduti attacco abbiamo
imparato benissimo vediamo dall'altra
questa volta irritante dai finora e
farli saltare nel pavimento
ok poi non so perché ma ho la sensazione
che se dobbiamo scappare da un ragazzo
mangione anche possa finire
ma ecco vita ne prendi uno scivolo che
bene e che è rimasto incastrato la
temuta riusciti a scappare mi sembra
strano che ne è stato così facile
infatti ha detto che c'è chi mangerà ha
detto mi mangerò tutti cerchiamo di
sbrigarsi perché ho paura che stia
arrivando per mangiarci le patatine
questo è che i prof piace e tutte le
mozioni
proprio come piace aiuto a scorrere
delle norme si vuole fare a fettine
apposta per poi mangiarsi meglio
addirittura ci sono delle asce qua aiuto
e vitale devo dire che non porti
affettare caduta ed è questo forse non
ho capito bene cosa ha detto però sembra
molto arrabbiato ma parlando con la
bocca piena sta andando bene finora
possiamo farcela
ma dove stiamo andando guarda poi
bisogna salire la sopra attento brutte
cose per risorse fatto qui per voi in
quale dei rum ho preso questo tappeto
arcobaleno vediamo chi lo sa chi guarda
tutte le nostre pitt luxury spa velino
sto benissimo
ok stiamo per uscire da questo stage non
lascia mai fatta saliamo dove finiremo
destino siamo nella bocca no nella bocca
sì ci sono tanti li guarda no non siamo
nella bocca
siamo in un gabinetto non gabinetto con
la bocca mostrava ci sono gli occhi la
bocca i denti ma siamo in un gabinetto
perché mi fa paura questa cosa e vi
spiegabile ai bambini stati i denti non
si capisce perché allontaniamo l'inter
che a binetto malefico paura questi sono
tutti i batteri che stanno mi ricorda un
libro che ho letto da piccola che era
capital mutanda e i gabinetti parlanti
nome divertentissimi comunque mi
piacevano fatto praticamente succedeva
che i bambini ti prendevano vita e
volevano mangiare si teme persone
avevano idea ma cosa sono queste ed e
getti d'aria meglio evitarli sì voglio
vedere il gabinetto d'acqua guarda che
ora si può prendere a tema in un
lavandino benissimo come un bagno
lavandino con le papere
ma questi frizzi e poi qua dove
dentifricio il gabinetto e proprio
enorme non so perché sotto è pieno
d'acqua o si è allagato il bagno ecco
vitale laggiù ce la farà acqua bisogna
scegliere uno dei tre spazzolini vediamo
se riesco a capirlo con gli indizi che
mi avete dato voi sos spariscono non
puoi salire quindi forse questo non è
neanche giallo e rosso ecco ecco la
lettera direi giallo io gli dico blu
questi sono dei pettini bimbetti mi
basta passare attraverso che è stato
facile perché ci sono delle ossa in
questo bagno italia guarda siamo sopra
al gabinetto nel cotto dove c'è l'acqua
ha capito che così non si sa perché se
la carta igienica è però dobbiamo 84 di
tutto allagato e che cosa sono uno dei
palloncini quali si sono dei phone
iphone che proprio lasciato prima
che qui nella presa d'aria e sta andando
bene siamo fatti però dobbiamo scendere
che cos'è quello che arrabbiati di moro
capito perché tu mi sa che la gente
aspetta il ragazzo mangione che io
proprio la rete di melo vuole mangiarsi
ne sono sicura che si volgerà che
ovunque molto divertente queste skype ma
anche se non si capisco perché quasi
sono delle banconote
penso di andare piano piano si stiamo
qua ti la pizza guarda il ragazzo
mangione e dentro il gabinetto e dentro
cammino non fatemi finire nella sua
bocca nella soap
ma se caduta è che succederà no non mi
dire che simbolo che entro il gabinetto
no che provengo da assegnare
c'è scritto siamo stati ingoiati presto
ciò che vediamo questa volta che cosa ha
mangiato perché di voi non sappiamo che
cosa hanno mangiato e quando tutto per
l'intero ultimamente non masticano
niente allora abbiamo burger un hot dog
e una purezza ma è stato poi verdure
anche di brutto saliamo sulla spina
dorsale e qualcuno forse qualcosa di
strano ti facevano c'è qualcuno con una
spada tipo che ci sta facendo a fette
non lo so perché può fare questa cosa
per fortuna quello disturbatore se n'è
andato dunque proviamo ad è arrivato qui
dobbiamo evitare la cagnetta andiamo
stiamo ancora nella pancia della ragazza
e mangione core a quante cose ha
mangiato bello essere qua ci sono delle
lattine di qualcosa di bello
ecco vitale che muore quasi sono
addirittura dei gelati interi come
queste cose ci sono tre gelati poi cosa
solo degli yogurt forse ma è proprio
vero che e mangione questo ragazzo
cupcake
ovviamente mi sta venendo fame dove
vitale dal via andiamo forse forse siamo
riusciti a finire così il rum
vediamo ora lasciamo braida dove abbiamo
benito vediamo ma siamo salviamo e dice
di giocare per 5 minuti per sbloccare i
modi comandi mode che vuol dire a me non
è mai successa questa cosa mi sposo
questo è un altro
un ragazzo è vitale ma siamo qua sopra
c'è qualcosa qui guarda dove stiamo
stiamo nel gabinetto vediamo sembra
scordare di rado si vogliono riuscire
andare davanti se si riesca con questa
cosa verde mi ha dato il tappeto no
possiamo andare in giro col tappeto
volante nella guerra che bello quando il
ragazzo madonna era dentro che obiettano
h perché noi siamo riusciti a uscire da
questa enorme scape rumorosità mi sono
sposato volante sono andato a sbattere
su una casa e bellissimo poter volare lo
rende schifo magari o no è infatti se
quello che è successo che man sono
rientrare però siamo chiusi la seves
facendo i ritorni al punto di prima
ok meno male però potrei rifare le ski
troncon tappeto mi si è tolto il tappeto
per un momento comunque bellissimo
volare forum
ma questa era l'altra parte delle skype
room possiamo vedere se sono qui proprio
di fronte a te si sono sbloccati mod
guardiamo il fuoco e poi questo che
cos'è wow
fring per andare più veloce forse per
salire di più ma anche teletrasporto e
che cosa hai fatto bene sapere che il
promo del ragazzo mezz'ora che voto ti
diamo loro a 10 di dopo otto e mezzo
zoom8 voi che cosa ti date da 1 a 10
ora vi lasciamo ancora quattro casse
gigliate puoi cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite
buona visione